The Joe Rogan Experience all they have
to do is have a good headline the inside
of it could be nonsense and they can
even show you in front right in front of
your face why what they're saying is
incorrect and it doesn't matter and then
they all [__] and whine and then they
go why is no one watching our content
well here's the wildest one that's going
on right now you know the Mar-A-Lago
controversy of the the price pricing or
the uh the inflated value of the house
yeah
the judge ruled that it was worth 18
million
it's 20 acres in like the most expensive
real estate in that area like a house
down the street from it much smaller it
just sold for 50 million dollars wow
even if Forbes said it's worth somewhere
between I think see if what Forbes said
I think they said it was worth between
300 and 700 million dollars and uh
they were saying that it's worth 18
million
it's like they don't even try to pretend
yeah
if the guy says his house is worth a
billion dollars right
and then you come along and say no no
it's worth like 800 million Forbes says
it's worth as much as 700 million we'll
call it 700 million now you got a
reasonable argument yeah but if you say
18 million like you got it no that's a
palace the place is a palace it's 20
acres
get the [__] out of here this is great
you can't do that that's like too
obvious that you're just you don't give
a [__] about the truth they don't you
don't give a [__] about the truth oh he
claimed it was worth 1.5 billion in
latest plea to drop fraud case but judge
ruled it's wildly inflated yeah but the
judge does not have a an accurate sense
of the market in my opinion it just the
property size alone it's such a giant
chunk of property
that says it's worth somewhere about
half a bill right is that what is that
what that's no see he said the judge was
saying that it's worth between eight oh
it says Okay
um citing an appraisal report from the
city of Palm Beach that pegged the value
of Mar-A-Lago between 18 million and
27.6 million between 2011 2021 right
okay so it was 18 million announced
worth because of inflation 27.
um 325 million that's how much Forbes
estimated Mar-A-Lago is worth as of
September although we pick its net value
at 292 million after deducting roughly
33 million in debt okay so it's got debt
so I think with this what they're saying
the scam is is you wildly over inflate a
piece of real estate again I don't know
jack [__] about real estate all right
just to just but I think what you do is
you say I got a house worth a billion
dollars I need a loan
based on this billion dollar property
you have but if then they send an
appraiser to you I'll say hey but this
house worth 18 million then you're like
uh oh so now you really got a loan but
you got a loan based on something that's
not really worth is so I think they're
collateral or whatever it is it would
the reason why they would give you that
much money doesn't make any sense but
clearly that can't be accurate if you're
seen pictures of that [__] place yeah
show some photos of Marlo
if that was 18 million dudes would be
buying them every day right that would
it would last three seconds on the
market before somebody bought it people
would just be calling up the phone lines
would get jammed yeah I'll take it sight
unseen I'll take it yeah 18 million I
mean even 27 million calling a 1.5
billion is a trump thing
my favorite thing about the whole speech
is he talks about himself in the third
person the judge hates Trump that's what
he keeps saying that is it that's a nice
house
[__] Palace man look at that place
she's insane and the inside of it is all
like look click on that photo of trump
there with the chandelier look how
[__] beautiful it is inside
man that is ridiculous I mean look maybe
it's me being a Brit but I look at it go
it's a bit [__] much that oh it's a
lot much
my style that looks like something out
of a Russian tsar's house you know what
I mean that's what I like about it
if Trump lived in some [__] [__]
Log Cabin I'd be so disappointed right
right Trump lived in like [__] John
dutton's house on Yellowstone yeah Dylan
bro you should be balling that's on
brand as you say that's on brand what a
house look at the size of that property
yeah yeah so those little houses around
there selling for like 30 billion
dollars wow like that's crazy expensive
property there yeah to think that that's
only worth 18 million to 27 million
that's that seems a little insane you
know the thing that always gets me man
is I you read in the mainstream media
and they criticize our podcast and in
your show and and then they go these
people spread misinformation I'm like
mate what are you talking about you have
been spreading misinformation from day
one you know what I mean yeah it's like
getting an electron dating from Ted
Bundy you're like mate come on yeah it
seems crazy for them to keep harping on
that at this point it's like don't you
know about the internet people have made
they've made like compilation videos of
you guys being wrong over and over and
over and over and over again and you've
never apologized for it the I mean
whatever you want to talk about whether
it's the the Russia collusion thing or
the saying the dangers of trump denying
the election then you show like how many
people denied Trump's election right
yeah because they call them the
illegitimate president Hillary called
him and he was just my present yeah they
said he stole the election like that
kind of if you think that's dangerous
from him then it's dangerous from you
too and we should all acknowledge that
we should try to figure out a way to
make the elections as Fair as possible
my real fear is that not everybody's on
board with that that's my real fear I
would love to believe that everybody on
the right and everybody on the left just
wants a fair battle and they just want
to be able to speak their mind to the
public and have the people choose that's
what I would like like to believe and
that we would like to encourage all
Americans to vote everyone should just
get informed and go out there and give
your opinion let's see how the country
feels yeah
but I don't know how much Shenanigans is
going on you know there's a little you
know there's a little collusion between
you know social media companies we know
that now that's that's kind of scary
that's kind of scary that you would
think that what you believe is so
important that you're willing to
manipulate an election
that scares you it's just it should
scare us because it's like man they
could use that on you I mean we could
have this imagine if there's like we
have this [__] amazing person who's
running for president and like finally
all rational people in the center people
the rational on the right and the left
agreed this person as the country's best
ideas in mind and we've made like
awesome progress with the way this
person is communicating with everybody
and seems like they could really unite
us and they get [__] somebody comes in
and just manipulates it doesn't like the
idea of some new person taking charge
doesn't like somebody the idea is some
radical thinker who wants to try to make
things as good as possible for the whole
country and that maybe there's a way to
do that and they get [__] by some
establishment spokesperson
because they know how to manipulate the
system and look at the thing the people
that rise to the top in the current
system in your country and in ours I
mean the idea that these two people
whoever they end up being if it's Biden
and Trump let's say these are the best
people out of 320 million [__] people
well the thing about Biden is he's
already won right so he is the president
so it only makes sense that he runs for
president if he's physically capable of
doing that
the thing about Trump is there's you
know the narrative that he and a lot of
his followers put out is that the
election was rigged and that you know he
should be the legitimate the legitimate
president anyway and no one else is
there's no one's voting for anybody else
like these hardcore trumpers they're
going to go all in on Trump so it's like
okay how else could it be other than
Trump versus Biden unless they arrest
Trump unless they figure out a way to
make some of these charges stick
here's the thing with Trump you know you
know to him this isn't this is no longer
a presidential race to him this is
existential because this is probably the
only chance he's gonna have of avoiding
jail so you look at it like that and you
think Trump is already a guy who let's
put it bluntly I'm mildly we'll do
whatever it takes to win
and if
you could put a guy like that and you
say
the only way that you're going to avoid
Joe is to win the presidency you're
already notching it up a few ratchet
when it comes to making the atmosphere
really toxic and you can play that
argument the other way I mean in terms
of Biden and the investigations that are
happening Donald Trump gets elected what
is he going to do that they would argue
that too right yeah
the bone thing's fascinating to watch
people to ignore it did you see Noam
Dorman's interview with that guy uh did
no you never saw oh man it's a numb
Dormer from the seller from the comedy
seller oh okay he had a guy on his
podcast who he build up as like the most
sane uh guy who says the the hunter
Biden thing was nothing burger and they
went round for like an hour and the guy
just would not it was the craziest thing
that I've ever seen I'll send it to you
okay yeah it's a journal from The
Washington Post yeah yeah yeah and he
thinks it's nothing yeah yeah but but
when was he doing mental gymnastics yeah
so when Norm essentially Corners him and
goes no no look at this look at this the
guy just he just he wants to leave
that's it